you talked about moral victory can you
explain how your morality contributes to
the way see the value of winning sure
I think there's absolutely such a thing
as a moral victory and sometimes people
that are trying to manipulate you or
trying to get you to buy something will
tell you differently and you know there
is there it goes in two directions for
instance let's say you're a blue belt
and you compete against you know a real
black goal and there's plenty of people
running around plat belts that are not
particularly at this point but you know
let's say for instance your blue belt
and you compete against a real black
belt the likelihood of you winning is
almost zero however if you go out there
and you try hard and you do your best
and again whether you come off the mat
you know a winner which would be very
fortunate and unlikely but or you come
off the mat you know on the other side
of things if you went after and you
tried and you you know let's say you had
some nerves but you kept that in check
and you fought hard you didn't let it
get the better of you you know that
would be in my opinion a moral victory
and and there would be nothing wrong for
recognizing it as such now that's not
the same thing as an actual physical
victory but there's nothing wrong with
saying let's say you're your opponent's
260 pounds in your 120 and you tie they
get the decision hey you know I remember
that happened to me at the quarter-final
or not the quarter-final rather in the
the third round at the absolute in the
Worlds in 2008 you know and you know
it's against a heavyweight or a super
heavyweight and in the 0-0 and I wasn't
happy about losing by any stretch of the
imagination but looking back I'm like
okay well you know generally speaking if
you end up level considering that I have
all of the resources you don't that is
you know you definitely performed a
little bit better than I did now at the
end of the day you know wins and losses
do matter and you do want to try to make
sure that I'm not shooting for the moral
victory I'm shooting for the actual
victory but every now and then it's very
very important to keep in mind that you
know am I just actually myself am i
conducting myself in a way that I
respect that hopefully other people of
value or respect and also a way that I
believe is going to produce actual
victory and actual positive results in
the long run as well I think it's
important to recognize that because
sometimes you'll see people get very
frustrated let's say for instance if I
box against people that are much more
experienced than me all the time
you know I'm not going to win anyone
that tells you differently has either
not training with people that are very
good or B they have no idea what they're
talking about
but what I can say is hey did I do a
little bit better today and better
doesn't mean that I land more punches in
this it was I more under control was I
more able to kind of keep my keep my
focus and execute what I wanted to
execute and if the answer to that is yes
you know I'm moving in the right
direction so as far as I'm concerned
there's all sorts of different types of
moral victory but it would be the the
same thing as you know let's say for
instance you know fade or slaps your
mother you got to hit him
you have to he's going to kick the
out of you almost certainly but you have
to hit him it would not be it would be a
technical like well I didn't get hurt so
that's a win if you ran away but that
would be the opposite of the moral
victory in that case trying your best
and losing would still be I would say
the honorable thing to do so what you're
saying is sometimes you have to pay the
price for a moral victory
absolutely but the reality is is that
martial arts doesn't just teach us about
how to beat someone up or technique or
this is that that's really not the core
of the martial arts the core of the
martial arts is heart discipline
dedication focus and if you have those
things they'll always be people better
than you and they'll always be people
lesser than you but that's not the only
metric by which you can judge
performance or judge a person